why do you think it is that there's more
gay men than gay women
that continues to be debated now you
have to understand that the scholarly
issue or the scientific issue is
how does homosexuality continue at all
why is it repeated out of the gene pool
yeah
yeah
nature is against it since it doesn't
reproduce
and a lot of cultures have been against
it although some have tolerated it but
certainly the last few centuries uh you
know so we look to nature and culture as
the two big explanations for once they
agree
on not favoring homosexual activity and
yet it continues to survive uh there's
some interesting answers
starting to emerge
one of my
colleagues in uh
at the university of queensland
brendan's each uh a paper in science and
i think the second one coming along
uh
finding out that
okay yes there are genes
that predict uh
homosexuality it's not a particular gay
gene as they were once saying and
periodically they found one uh in
contrast it's sort of the combined
activity of hundreds if not thousands
of them
um
and the interesting finding
is that the siblings
of the gays who the heterosexual the
brothers and sisters are heterosexual
you know this so also is gay um his
brother is heterosexual and he has more
sexual partners than the average man
so the way i put it is that the super
manly man who only
is entirely masculine in all his traits
he doesn't relate to women all that well
it helps a man to be attractive to women
to have a little more emotionality and
warmth and nurturance and and all these
things they like some degree
uh of of feminine traits to be present
they like a manly man too uh but some of
it helps
so it becomes a hit the middle problem
uh you want to have more
of these genes which will produce more
feminine traits
uh in the man
but maybe beyond a certain amount since
they're being
mixed together at random in the in the
fetus
um
that
may be a high amount then
turns him to where he'd be more
attracted to other men
and so that becomes
his genes made him homosexual which
again nature doesn't reward since it
does
that sex doesn't produce children
but
the same configuration of genes just a
little bit on the other side of the
border produces extra
uh children
uh by making
the others more more attractive and
and that's enough to keep the uh
the genes replenished in each generation
so it will continue uh to appear that is
so interesting so a couple of things
first off
one of the best tactics that you should
have if you're a guy that wants to be
successful with women is to have a gay
brother basically that genetically
you're going to have a hormonal profile
a genetic profile that's going to be
good for you and also it kind of
suggests that gay men
are a lot closer to highly successful
heterosexual men
than we might think you know you've got
not too far away from the genes also i
saw in your book didn't it say that um
monozygotic twins identical twins
have a 50
likelihood
of the other twin being gay if one of
the twins is gay
yes uh those data are a little while ago
i don't know
if there's any update or anything but
that was an estimate which shows there's
a lot of nature and a lot of culture i
mean 50 likelihood of being gay that's
way above the
probably two or three percent
uh
maybe amongst four in the population so
it's if you're if your twin brother is
gay and you're an identical twin yeah
the odds are much higher than average on
the other hand 50 is far from 100 it's
not determined
uh and
[Music]
and
again the true number may be a little
higher than that because some people
don't want to be gay
and will resist acknowledging it
but
nevertheless i think this is a sign that
there's ample input from both nature and
culture what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
you